[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Amy in
Charlotte North Carolina hey Amy welcome
to the Ramsey show thank you for taking
my
call sure what's up I have a question so
I just um I'm about to close on a house
it's a
$330,000 house that I put 18% down so I
put 60,000 on down and so the house
comes in bare doesn't have refrigerator
nothing at all and of course those are
the things that I have to buy and I'm
just wondering um like how should I go
about it without getting into
debt did you know I'm just I have to ask
going into buying this house did you
know that there wasn't going to be any
appliances Inside Yes I I did know so
what's your
plan you know what so I I have um so I I
put aside so I I still have like
20,000 um kind of like kind of you know
kind of my sa my saved up um to just um
just get things at really bare minimum
and I have lived 35 years without having
to ever buy Furnitures so everything is
going to be Brad like if I have to get
everything from beds to fridge to washer
and dryer yeah that 20,000 no was that
your emergency fund
correct yeah I don't I don't want you to
use your emergency fund for something
that's not an
emergency so let's just play pretend a
minute you close on a $330,000 house you
spend your last $220,000 Furnishing it
the next day something's going to go
wrong and you have no
money right that's why Jay doesn't want
you to spend your emergency
fund so how how should I do about them
how should I go about I mean that was
your plan to move into the house
broke
yeah so so that Dave said it that was
your plan to move into the you're going
to have to move very slowly and very
methodically what do you make I make um
I make uh 35 tax free and I make around
like 40 has to be
taxed so I make um 75 70 yeah around
there how where do you get taxfree
income um from um retirement from the
military like disabilities okay so
what's your what do you bring home each
month help me out 5,000
okay so let's see here and you're
completely debt free or did you buy this
house with no $330,000 mortgage no no no
I meant other debt oh you have other
debt so I have no other debt and I
finance house
275,000 oh you put 60 down on 330
purchase okay that's better okay so what
this looks like is every month you're
going to be doing a detailed budget in
order to figure out how much margin do
you have to put towards what the most
important thing is so if I'm you I'm
making a priorities
list the the place you live now do you
have furniture in it no I I'm I'm
renting a room so everything is
furnished and I'm not sure if that
relevant but my boyfriend's gonna be
moving in and my other question is it's
going to be my house and he's going to
help me pay for mortgage and I'm trying
to pay it be like kind of within like 20
years and he's going to help me have the
mortgage but since he's in my house and
I wonder what is the fair amount that he
should pay in because I you know at the
end of the day if we don't work out it's
gonna be my house and I don't want to
screw somebody over and what do you guys
think is fair so you get that's my um
yeah okay so let me back up to the other
part first okay um you're renting a room
and you don't own a bed no I don't own
anything at all okay all right um the
the first thing I want you to do is I
want you to take
$5,000 and go buy a mattress and a bed
and I want you to buy a used
refrigerator and I want you to use the
laundry mat until you can save up the
money and buy wash and dryer that's
going to leave you 15,000 in your
emergency fund and then you're going to
cash flow Furnishing this place out of
your income so every month or two you're
going to buy another Appliance another
piece of furniture and you're going to
pay cash as you go the you don't do this
with a mattress but everything else in
the house go to the rich end of town and
go to the garage sale and you can buy a
$9,000 leather couch for 500 bucks at a
garage sale in the rich end of town cuz
the lady redecorated and didn't like the
color anymore okay and that's how you're
going to furnish this place the first
round of furniture um get a decent
refrigerator that's kind of gets life
started you can go to the laundry mat
until Christmas and then you can save up
and buy a washer and dryer if you want
to do it faster you can buy a used
washer and dryer and later on upgrade to
a new one all with cash and sell your
used one on Craigslist okay so you're
going $15,000 you have to keep in the
account $5,000 budget to get you started
with a bed and a refrigerator and a
couple of other items okay okay does
that make sense to you that way if you
you have an emergency you don't lose
your home
yeah that would be so you know I feel
like you know I I got a beautiful house
and my my mentality took it all you took
it all the way to the edge kiddo I mean
you left no margin in this deal I mean
you can't you can't breathe the way
you've got this tightened up so tight
then the second piece is um I don't
recommend that you ever buy a house or
depend on someone that you're not
married to to pay for your house and so
if you're going to choose to shack up
with him um I would PR my preference as
an old guy who has a couple of daughters
and I know how sometimes people get
treated in these situations is I would
say he can't move in unless he got
married cuz there's kind of that thing
you know and it's much better for you
you're the one that comes out on the
short end of the stick not the
guy Oh I thought it was the other way
around no you're the one that comes out
that does not go well for the ladies in
these situations economically
the economics really suck for the ladies
and these things so um and somehow guys
keep talking them into it but I'm not
sure how um so I you know I'll just be
old fogy and you can be mad at me if you
want to I love you and I want you to win
and I'm telling you the truth of what I
would do if I were in your shoes or what
I do tell my little sister or my best
friend or whatever he doesn't move in
unless he gets married um you run your
own life and if he's a man and wants to
step up and serve his uh spouse then
yeah he can come on board here and we'll
go aside from that if you're going to do
this don't depend on him to do it and
then you can just decide there's not a
fair price for shacking up there's not a
shacking up schedule we don't have a
schedule for that uh there's not a price
on it so um you just got to decide you
know who's paying for the mustard who's
paying for the mayonnaise who's paying
for the bread who's paying for the
lights who's paying for the water or
what percentage or whatever and you got
a roommate you know it's a roommate
situation and it's just like in college
that's my mustard you know I mean it's
the same stuff and so uh that's the
problem you get into and it doesn't bode
well statistically the data points don't
bode well for your future wealth
building in this scenario and it doesn't
even bode well for his future wealth
building there's actually what we call a
marital advantage in the statistics out
there in the data people who are married
have an economic advantage over those
who are not the data is slam dunk it's
not even close so something to consider
I got all up in your business but you
asked darling so um but yeah as far as
the house goes 15,000 in the account get
a refrigerator in a bed use furniture on
the rest of it work your way up with
cash flow what do you think I yeah I I
was shocked you gave her the 5,000 out
of the 20 if I'm being honest but well I
think she's going to go buy a
refrigerator I don't think we can stop
her look Jade warshaw would have said
you better get you a air mattress and
stop
playing I'm not telling her to get a
real mattress you get an air mattress
and you get you a college refrigerator
I'm talking about the little guy that
goes on the floor because I want this as
a reminder to never do dumb stuff like
that again yeah never take never take
yourself all the way the edge yeah
that's the dumb thing you took yourself
all the way the edge and then what
should have been a blessing can end up
being a curse and that's what we're
afraid for honey living like a rapper in
this in this big old house and no
furniture with no furniture that's
rappers live I didn't know that giant
gold chain I didn't know that okay and
no money just learned something